we define ourselves by our ocean around
how we live how we survive
and if that disappears it would be
devastating
[Music]
my name is Lukas Assad and I work as a
researcher here at Palau International
coral reef center today we are going to
a very special place and we are going to
count and identify corals
allow his collection of hundreds of
islands maybe 250 about seven to eight
degrees north of the Equator south east
of the Philippines and north of Irian
Jaya
there's about 27,000 people we live very
much off the land and you've done so for
many many years
coral is really planted and animal so
the color that you see in the world is a
plant that uses sunlight and then the
coral animal is the part that builds the
skeleton the plant part of the animals
marketed in symbiosis happily together
for Lisa important in so many different
ways so many different people whether
that be food whether that be a source of
income it's a unique habitat with unique
species that sleeps throughout the world
to find firm for everybody
the reefs of the world are in the
decline they've been on the decline for
quite some time now it's attributed to
many different reasons but climate
change is the common enemy
it has no leads to be heartbreaking we
just lose very big part of our identity
and culture in our way of life
I think cloud would cease to be you
don't have big skyscrapers we don't have
to figure an ark this is like our
landmark and when that's gone not be put
out at all but I think there is hope
something seems to be magical here in
kalau the water has been identified to
be very acidic and very high in
temperature the same conditions are
what's predicted for the world's oceans
in 50 years and yet we see vibrant coral
many species of corals growing on top of
each other
there is something to be learned from
these spaces maybe it's something to do
with the corals themselves maybe
something to do with the environment we
are beginning to understand some factors
but this is a very big question for us
we can unlock the mystery of Palau could
be what the future would look like for
the world for me
[Music]
[Music]
they're students a lot to learn but we
know at least that for now that kind of
a vision in the darkness of destruction
of the college we know that there's some
corals that are doing pretty much okay
and we need to replicate that
[Music]